Good morning, Hank, it's January 10th 2012, the day that The Fault In Our Stars comes out!
It's actually Monday January 9th
but I have to make this video now because tomorrow I got to be doing a bunch of things.
It's Question Tuesday, the day that I answer real questions from real nerdfighters.
"How you doing?"
Good, I'm just a tiny bit stressed out. I have to leave my family for a month,
which is kind of a bummer, but I'm excited to go on tour. How are YOU doing?
You can't answer, you're inside of the camera.
"I hope I get my copy today so I can lick your signature."
Um that's not a question, but I don't recommend licking sharpie that- that's bad for you.
"So what inspired you to write The Fault In Our Stars? "
Almost twelve years ago, I worked as a student Chaplain at a children's hospital,
ever since then I've been trying to write a funny, honest story about it and
It just, y'know, took a while.
Long while.
"Do you think The Fault In Our Stars is your best book yet?"
I don't know. The reviews have definitely been better than for any of my other books,
but authors shouldn't be trusted to judge their own work;
I don't think like Mark Twain thought that his best book was Joan Of Arc. Yeah. No.
Hank, I gotta go pack and stuff. Walk with me.
"Could an unladen swallow carry a copy of The Fault In Our Stars in its talons?"
Well definitionally not, as it would then be a laden swallow.
Do you like this tie?
"Was it hard to write The Fault In Our Stars as a parent?"
I don't think I could write it UNTIL I was a parent.
"How much research did you have to do about the medical stuff in the The Fault In Our Stars?"
More than a hypochondriac probably should.
"What made you decide to write this one from a girl's point of view?"
That's pretty hard to answer without spoilers.
But part of it was that I wanted to think about the way gender constructions
shape our understanding of what constitutes heroism.
"Do you think V for Vendetta is a proponent of democracy or anarchy?"
I think V for Vendetta is primarily a proponent of a very specific and pervasive idea of heroism.
"Will you do peanut butter face?"
I'm in an airport, people'll think that I'm crazy .Alright, fine, hold on.
Do you guys have any peanut butter crackers?
These are the best I could do.
Happy?
"Will I feel out of the loop if I haven't read Looking For Alaska?"
No, it's not like Harry Potter;
my books don't have anything to do with each other.
"What genre of music are The Hectic Glow?"
The genre of awesome.
"Hey, my pre-order wasn't signed."
Don't panic.
Just email <sparksflyup@gmail.com> with your name, address and the place where you ordered the book.
"Did you ever get emotional while writing this book?"
Yeah, quite a bit actually
but I'm a crier.
"Wait is The Fault In Our Stars gonna make me cry or laugh or what?"
Well, ideally it's going to make you feel
ALL OF THE THINGS.
[Singing] People in the airport think that I'm crazy, the people in the airport think that I'm crazy.
I probably shouldn't have done that while doing a dance. That's probably-
Let's face it. There's nobody in the airport.
Seriously, I got this whole section to myself.
There were some people here
but they left when I started talking into a video camera.
"Was Esther an inspiration for this book?"
Definitely. There's no way I could have ever written The Fault In Our Stars unless I'd known Esther.
But at the same time it's really important to note that Hazel is not Esther. The book is made up.
I wrote a novel. I promise.
"Does The Fault In Our Stars contain anything about fruit?"
I don't think so.
I think- that might be one of its insufficiencies is a failure...
to tackle fruit.
"Are there any tickets left to anywhere on the Tour De Nerdfighting?"
Yeah, if you live near New Orleans, Houston, Austin Phoenix, Albuquerque, Seattle or San Francisco.
Otherwise no, I'm sorry.
Ticket info in the doobly-doo.
Is this real life?!
HEEEEEY
"Has Nerdfighteria influenced your writing at all?"
As you'll probably see in reading it,
Nerdfighteria has shaped this book in so many ways that I can't even list them .
"What was your favorite moment in the creation of The Fault In Our Stars?"
So, Hank, Islamic mystics have this word "Fanaa"
which means like dissolution or annihilation of the self
and for me, that's what reading and writing do, when they're working
and when I was writing The Fault In Our Stars,
I was very, very lucky to have many moments where I felt like I wasn't me,
like I was somehow
transcending the limits of myself
and that was really great.
And I can only hope that readers will have that experience.
Thank you all for reading The Fault In Our Stars,
I hope that you like it.
DFTBA, best wishes.
Hank, I will see you in a minute when I go over to your room.